foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday March 8th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
you are probably familiar with the
concept of facial recognition you may
have just used it to unlock your phone
the use of facial recognition is growing
concert venues Sports Arenas even
airlines are beginning to let people use
their faces as their tickets and while
that may seem convenient some lawmakers
are looking to tighten regulations
around this kind of tech citing privacy
concerns and allegations of bias with me
to discuss the increasing use of facial
recognition Tech and how to keep your
data safe is our personal Tech columnist
Nicole Nguyen hey Nicole thanks for
joining us hi Zoe Nicole I'm sure a lot
of listeners have a general idea of what
facial recognition Tech is but can you
give us a brief overview of how it works
facial recognition Tech as it is today
is basically face matching software some
software takes an image of you maybe via
camera in real life or they look at a
government-issued ID and then when you
approach that technology via an entry
point like a boarding gate for example
people before you're about to get on an
airline that camera and the software
behind it will match your face that it
sees in the camera to your government
issued ID
okay so a boarding gate seems like a
little bit of a new place that I might
be encountering this what are some of
the newer places that people might
experience facial recognition Tech the
US government has been using facial
recognition technology for a long time
in places like airports and at border
crossings but increasingly you'll see
facial recognition Tech in places like
concert venues stadiums and in airports
especially I recently encountered the
tech at a trade show conference in
Barcelona where there were tens of
thousands of attendees and the
technology was sort of used as an
express lane to get people really
quickly through the venue to the trade
show floor okay
your face your ticket that seems a
little bit handier it's certainly
difficult to lose that but how safe is
this data I mean with anything I think
we worry about what happens to this
information it really depends on where
you are in the European Union where I
attended this conference the law
dictates that anyone who uses facial
recognition has to delete that data
within 28 days of the final use of the
service and that data must be stored in
Europe in the U.S the laws are a little
bit different there are smattering of
state-based laws in places like
California and Illinois but there is no
federal law governing facial recognition
and so consumers really have to look
into the Privacy policies of these
companies if they're concerned with
their biometric data being shared
elsewhere okay so what can people do to
protect their biometric data well you
can certainly look at that company's
privacy policy to see how long they're
retaining the data where they're storing
it but ultimately you cannot predict
whether or not that company if they do
choose to keep your biometric data
chooses to Pivot in the future you know
maybe today they're an access point
entry company that's trying to process
people who are going through a stadium
maybe tomorrow they're signing up with
law enforcement to provide a facial
recognition product to police or other
agencies I imagine that some listeners
have heard about the issue of facial
recognition bias can you tell us what
the concerns around that are research
has showed that facial recognition
technology is not as accurate for people
of color or for women in general and so
if it's not accurate you know that may
not be as consequential if you're trying
to get through an express lane to a
stadium but the consequences are much
more grave if it's in the hands of law
enforcement and they're trying to arrest
somebody based on facial matching
software you mentioned some of the
differences between the US and Europe in
terms of where data can be stored by
these facial recognition companies I
mean is there a big difference overall
in how lawmakers are approaching this
kind of technology in the US it's very
state-based States like California and
Illinois have biometric data privacy
laws but outside of those States you're
not protected by those laws because
there is no federal law governing how
biometric data needs to be deleted
stored shared at the U.S level several
lawmakers have tried but those laws have
not made it through Congress in any
significant way but I think that we may
see more interest in the future as more
of these facial recognition access
points pop up in public places like I
said concert venues and stadiums and
places like that and what about in
Europe are they being more active there
in terms of initiating laws for facial
recognition well now that data privacy
laws in Europe dictate when companies
need to delete this data and where they
can store it and what they can do with
it and beyond that there are proposals
for Banning facial recognition for uses
like for identifying people in protests
for example in private spaces I think
it's generally acknowledged that if you
consent to facial recognition being used
on you then that's sort of an
appropriate use of it but at
non-appropriate use is the government
knowing your identity when you're in a
public square or at a test it seems like
there is go
more use of facial recognition if you
want to opt out of say all of it is
there a way to do that most of the
companies today allow you to opt out of
facial recognition unless you're at a
place like an airport where it's hard to
evade if you're going through an
international border but if it's a
private company like for example at City
Field where if you're attending a Mets
game most of the entry points have a
facial recognition Lane and a regular
schmegular ticket Lane
I think that over time the non-facial
recognition option could become very
cumbersome like for example you know
paying a cash at a toll booth rather
than using easy pass for those who
travel interstate on the east coast and
so if non-facial recognition options
become cumbersome then to opt out maybe
a huge pain in the future got it so our
our faces are now our tickets to
everything or maybe our faces will be
our tickets to everything in the future
yep that's right
all right that's our personal Tech
columnist Nicole Nguyen thanks for
joining us Nicole thanks for having me
alright that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]